Iris first time here at the junior girls
competition first victory for you in the
tournament describe to us your emotions
right now
but I was able to win at least a game
and maybe get some confidence back after
I got a half point out of three in the
first three rounds definitely a good
victory for you but it wasn't an easy
game right out of the opening it felt
like she was putting some pressure but
then she took this Pawn on A7 and she
gave you something to work with did you
like this sacrifice how did you assess
the position at this point yeah I was a
little surprised that she did it
um I thought it gave me too many Tempe
to like get my Rooks in play
um but what was annoying about it was
that I couldn't try like trying B5
before was more difficult because I
didn't have the a pawn yeah
um but I think in the end it wasn't that
good for her because I got the open file
and that was pretty you got this nice
Bishop in play that you couldn't before
because of the pressure on
H6 how did you feel about your chances
once you sacrificed
because it was kind of back and forth
one tempo type of position yeah I I
wasn't really sure but it definitely
felt like my um attack was a little
faster so I was pretty confident here
very nice and I think that's oh this
beautiful move Bishop C1 if you take
with the King then there's a couple of
checks and then you pick up the queen if
you take with the queen then Rook to A1
very very nice move by you Iris
beautiful game congratulations you must
be feeling quite proud about this game
who do you have tomorrow
um I honestly don't know
congratulations guys any questions for
Iris just our congratulations Iris uh
nice game nice win
as uh we once again just say Rochelle
fought her way back what was going